how are you Joe I'm good simple is right
up my alley
you need a simple call I'm your guy well
no seriously though Joe you know what I
mean by that though you know what I mean
by that it's it's simple catch sidelines
touchdown Vikings win I mean what else
what else can you say what it is TV I
mean that helps right not like you're
you're doing it on radio where you have
to describe the scene so we have a great
director and rich Rousseau and I let him
do his thing and I just shut up and
enjoy it with everybody else but it's
not easy to do that is essentially I'm
giving you a compliment even though it
might not have sounded that way Joe you
know I I know I know
deflecting right well I guess I'll ask
again
I mean you've done an elite announcer
for Fox since 96 so I mean how do you
stay in a moment like that nobody
expected that I'm sure you and Troy
weren't even expecting something like
that no it was like a lightning bolt and
I got to be honest with you as my
initial reaction maybe I was right maybe
I was wrong was for Diggs to get out of
bounds you know we when you watch the
replay and the time is in there he
caught it with three maybe four seconds
left and I thought [ __ ] out of bounds
and then that would have been stupid
because he was wide open going down the
sideline to the end zone so I when
you're in that moment and you're calling
it you think okay they need a pass to
the sideline they got a jump out of
bounds and have a shot at a field goal
the last thing you think about is what
happened is you know Williams makes that
kind of diving ducking action as the
safety and Diggs makes the catch turns
and goes up the sideline for the
touchdown I mean that was the furthest
thing from my mind
mm-hm Joe Buck who called the Viking
Saints yesterday joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show and where where does it
rank for you from what you called in
your career Joe well considering that it
was the first in essence walk-off
touchdown win in NFL playoff history
it's certainly the most recent
it's also the I think most exciting for
a singular moment I mean you just don't
get those in the NFL you may get those
in baseball obviously with a walk-off
home run you know it's kind of like the
Joe Carter homerun that I didn't call
Sean McDonough called on CBS when he
wanted for the Blue Jays back in the day
where you just have that one stamp and
that one moment that you know for Carter
worn a World Series in four digs and
keenum won a playoff game it's its top I
don't know two or three for me but its
first football I think it's it's
probably number one for exciting moments
that I've been a part of yeah and and
and and even to add to it again is the
dream of this team to play for the
Superbowl in their home building what is
it like in that town what did you take
in in the two-three days that you were
there in Minneapolis st. Paul area Joe
well I only only got fake moon once
Randy Moss that was good
that's called being ahead of the curve I
it was great I mean the whole city is
you can imagine is taken with this team
it's an easy team to root for it's kind
of got that underdog feel and the
stadium I'm jealous of Al and Chris to
call that Super Bowl out of that stadium
it is in my opinion my humble opinion
the best stadium in the NFL with regard
to brightness the sight line everything
that's involved there I just think they
hit a grand slam with that place and so
the stadium is just awesome
the place was louder than any I've been
in in a long long time so what - like in
bedlam and now after that play you know
with with one game separating the home
team from in essence a home Super Bowl
man I can't imagine what that city would
be like if they were looking at a home
game for Zimmer's crew on the 4th of
February yeah the skull chant if that
goes international that would be quite
something that it really a school I mean
that moment at the end of the game was
was you know it becomes ridiculous and I
get it the spread went to six points and
yeah I guess you got to play it honest
and you got a blind up for the
theoretical extra point which nobody
does and they just taken me and it was a
five point game but when they had that
moment out there and Keenum was in the
middle of that stadium think about where
he's been a record setter at the
University of Houston with regard to
passing yardage touchdowns and he was
undrafted on looked at and signed with
the hometown team and then he went to
st. Louis and then back to Houston that
back to st. Louis in LA and he was a
placeholder for Jared Goff and now he's
taking that team and grilling fashion to
the NFC Championship game it's when he
led that skull chant out in the middle
of the field that was just that gave me
chills as much as the touchdown
that was just an entire stadium and
quarterback leading the chant that
everybody was on the same page it was
just beautiful and Joe Buck of all the
quarterbacks he's gonna face in the NFC
Championship game it's the guy who was
traded to st. Louis
because for Sam Bradford for Chip Kelly
right and then Bradford Bradford degrees
of separation honestly st. Louis Rams it
is and you know especially since the
fact that Bradford winds up going to
Minnesota because of the injury to Teddy
Bridgewater allowing Wentz to get to the
point where he could start and then have
such an incredible season but he goes
down and the guy that steps in is Nick
Foles taking on the guy who also
replaced Sam Bradford it really is only
missing Kevin Bacon if you think about
it Joe it is and Jeff Fisher for some
weird reason I it goes back to the Rams
I mean Bradford was the number one
overall pick he was hurt one of the
reasons why that team and that franchise
went down the drain and ended up in LA
and then they all played musical chairs
and you've got Kenan against foals with
Bradford backing up Keenan Arcanum
three of which were a member of a brutal
st. Louis Rams team I think it just
doesn't make it can't even wrap your
head around that do you think anybody in
st. Louis is gonna care to watch though
what do you think
yeah they watch I think everybody here
is I sit here with snow on the ground
it's kind of over that whole thing I
last year was a lot of bitterness and in
2017 now 18 I think everybody's just
watching football again it is what it is
we hit on the number-one storyline for
the NFC Championship game right we
missing anything obviously there's the
coaches as well you got a backup
quarterback and Doug Peterson trying to
be the Super Bowl head coach or the
Eagles and Zimmer who's been waiting
forever for a job blossoming the way he
has as I'm what else first blush you
think you're gonna beat I was shocked
that think can't a page that had Zimmer
over his last ten in playoff games with
dates but after his days with the
Cowboys as first the position coach then
a coordinator then the coordinator in
Cincinnati where they went over for
during his time over one with the
Vikings from 2015 so it had been a while
for him and just a great honest what you
see is what you get head coach and and
like I said during the game you know at
some point I want to see him say please
Cleveland blown us all away I think he
just won't he just I think he's kind of
fighting himself for that and he leaves
open little crock when we met with him
on Friday he said if we're down double
digits in the second half I will not
hesitate to go to Bradford because he
throws it better than Keenum Bradford
coming off the bench even though he
hasn't played since what week four so
there's a lot of there's a lot going on
in this game that doesn't have the
sexiest NFC Championship matchup with
regard to the quarterbacks but I think
has one of the most intriguing matchups
of of NFC Championship game port of X I
can't wait it's gonna be a blast yeah I
can't wait to have you call it you would
Troy and the rest of the crew great job
yesterday Joe always a pre
she ate the call when you're going from
one place to the next and busy as all
get-out really appreciate it yeah my
pleasure
be well and maybe we'll talk next week I
hope well let's do that I don't mean to
book myself I'm not the opportunity to
come somebody cancels like I don't know
the kind of people you're like Matt
Damon cancels on you throw me a call
I'll see what I can do you know what Joe
we have just interesting enough unbooked
Matt Damon for next Monday and you're in
you're in you're in sharpie I just
sharpie you in Joe okay all right good
while your listeners can look forward to
that
great job Joe great stuff thanks again
that's Joe Buck the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience